now that all of the Nationwide race
riots have cured the coronavirus we have
decided to celebrate this public health
advancement by having our first-ever in
this studio in studio guest Steve dese
the host of the Steve DS show Steve
should we shake hey I don't know if this
is a felony to shake man you can
absolutely shake hands all right yes I
get it
it's on you especially because I want to
warn future in-studio guests yeah that I
am sitting on an OSHA violation right
now so I'm not normally this stiff but I
am afraid to move or deter this is the
platform that you were on yes it's about
four inches wide I feel like I need to
look at you and say we are from France
yeah I feel like I can't move yes so you
have been calling this for a little
while now this may be coronavirus is
being a little overhyped maybe the
public health genius experts The Exalted
doctor foul Qi maybe this is all being
oversold a little bit the events of the
past couple weeks I don't want to say we
told you so they seem to vindicate the
people who have been skeptical so back
in mid-march Michael I wrote a piece for
the blaze and the the point of the piece
was that we needed to separate the
pathology of the virus from the
psychology of the public policy that you
know we deal with ailments all of the
time the question is does the macro
threat to a culture yeah does it rise to
the level of threatening really the
things that that culture is the most
about its freedom its economy its
ability to maximize its potential how
about the simple things I mean hugging
and kissing my grandma yeah you know
having the kids think of all the kids
that didn't get a prom yeah think of all
the the the weddings that aren't
happening the graduation parties you
know we're not as a species we're not a
survival rate those events that we just
wiped out this year are what make life
worth living and so if we're gonna take
all of those things away we better make
sure that the data we have indicates
that it did and from the very beginning
the data did not clearly say that this
was the right path to be as fair as I
can be that maybe it was murky and maybe
if you want to say we did this for the
first 15 days to flatten a curve to
make sure I wouldn't even had done that
yeah thanks and the data need to go but
you would be open to yeah I can
understand why when you hear when a
virus mutates from animal to animal to
animal to human yeah and and we have
been studying corona viruses for decades
but we've not seen a phenomenon like
that I can see then that's what novel
coronavirus means does that mean that
the way that this infects is different
the way that this attacks is different
so I can understand why you wanted to
err on the side of caution all right but
if you go back and read what dr. John
I&I tes wrote at Stanford University in
his peer-reviewed white paper around
March the 17th the infection rates all
the numbers that are in there and he's
one of the heads of their population
health department over there J
Bhattacharya yeah that's absolutely
doing great what everything everything
that John put in his white paper I mean
he called like every stat that we now
have when he originally said this was
not the way to go and and I think and I
said I've got as I know you do I've got
friends of mine that are members of the
US Senate yeah I get people I know that
are members of Congress and I'm already
texting them and I'm already telling
them right now we need to have like a
Nuremberg like tribunal I mean okay
because because if we have shown we've
kind of shown our rear end here as a
people that you can scare us enough and
we'll just shut our economy and every
our way of life down I mean if you're
China right now why wouldn't you just
say oh guys we had Wuhan luck again
right before the Christmas shopping
season yeah and crushed the fourth
quarter of the American economy while
you're at it you brought up two very
important words here which I think is
the key to understanding this not just
as a matter of science but as a matter
of history and politics and those words
are choice and culture mm-hmm we make
choices I mean that's what politics is
right is we evaluate different problems
do we want a little more justice or a
little more mercy do we want a little
more freedom do we want a little more
equality right say these are eternal
questions and that's why our republic
was set up this way we persuade our
fellow citizens we pass laws and that is
the exalted political freedom that we
have for ourselves and then the left
came in here and the progressives and
the scientists with a capital S and they
said as they have been saying since Karl
Marx know there is a science to politics
there is a science to history there was
only one right answer you little people
can't debate this at all just listen to
the man in the lab coat he will tell you
live your life now it's been exposed
because these scientists were supposed
to give us the perfect answer I've been
going back and forth where the masks
don't wear the mask it spreads on tables
it doesn't spread on tables
it's caught it's spread by asymptomatic
people it's not spread by asymptomatic
people what is the effect of this going
to be on our politics because we've had
epidemics before right we had the
Spanish flu was was for Adnan Khan we
had the Hong Kong value but this
political reaction that's the only thing
that's been unique yes and that's why we
have to have a tribunal because because
the reason why is we have to if you go
back and read what Anthony Falchi Pope
Falchi the preeminent why yes if you
were if you read what he wrote in the
New England Journal of Medicine on
February the 28th and he said if you
want to know where the talking point if
your audience wants to know because I
mean we've been told that this came from
queueing on and from Mogga reddit forums
the talking point that this is just a
bad flu season came from the February
28th edition of the you of the New
England Journal of Medicine right if
then he thought she wrote those words
but then 11 days later now and and by
the way if you go back and look at what
he wrote in the New England Journal of
Medicine on February 28th all of the
numbers that he had in there are exactly
correct everything all the case fatality
rates that it's slightly were that worse
than a bad flu season all of that stuff
to prove to be correct in the end but
then eleven days later he went before
Congress and said this is ten times
worse than the flu and that occurred
that testimony occurred on March 11th
and that's when the country began going
into widespread lockdown we need to know
what what what changed from February
28th to March 11th right what who did he
speak to what piece of data did he
acquire that we are not privy to
unfortunately our media sucks yeah and
they just want to play you know they
want to play sophomoric games if they
could really ask critical questions of
the Trump task force that are
substantive but they're not interested
in substance and so there this is just
gotcha every single day but we need to
know what changed from February 28th to
March 11th what did he learn and here's
the other question we have to know I
keep like a personal journal in my mind
when I get to heaven these are the
questions I need to ask Jesus otherwise
I will not be
able to get not be able to rest you'll
be restless I need to know and here's
the latest one yeah how come
ox when it went at Oxford Stanford
Carnegie Mellon Rockefeller University
these are four of the greatest research
institutions we have in America well
Oxford's in the UK but when did they
become podunk giucose Whitney the guy
who founded the European Union's
infectious disease Center and who ran
who oversaw Sweden's effort when did he
become a flat earth right winger because
Sweden didn't lock down everyone else
locked down but not sweet right and and
all these countries that lock down were
the slowest country to reopen all over
the industrialized world yeah I mean
Israel is Israel originally imposed the
worst lockdown in the industrialized
world and then they became Sweden in
about 30 days so so we need to know
we're always told trust the experts well
which ones because when I first started
challenging the the narrative here I
really did anticipate because of my
political background that this was going
to be a derivative of the global warming
debate but a bunch of confirmation bias
versus right wingers right I was shocked
to see the amount of esteemed academics
from elite universities all over the
world
I mean Stanford care I'm sorry Oxford
came out the we a few days after the
Imperial College survey and said this is
BS we should not go by the Imperial
College survey was the one that
basically shut the world down that was
the original one that did and then and
but even recently you've had the guy who
was behind that study Neil Ferguson in
the UK who violated his own lockdown by
the way to sleep with his mistress that
high side story yeah but you had him
come out and admit that Sweden which did
not lock down was basically just as
successful at suppressing the virus as
the UK which did lockdown right and then
and then if most Americans had a choice
to go to either Stanford or the
University of Washington they're gonna
go to Stanford University Washington I'm
sure as a fine school but it's one of
those places you go to when you cannot
get in to Stanford right so can someone
explain to me why we allowed the AI hme
model which which it was wrong every
step of the way but it was taken as
gospel by Debbie Burks and Anthony
Falchi this is that's that's the model
then we Imperial Colleges would
originally shut the world down we
extended our
lockdown based on the AI hme models of
hospitalizations and the system was
going to be overrun if we didn't do this
they've been wrong every step of the way
and and there were tons of academics
even here in the United States who
challenged that model and yet though it
we have I don't know I don't understand
why no one at the White House was
interested in what they had to say you
know you make such a great point on the
universities because I would push back a
little bit and say some of our most
elite universities now are the ones that
seem to have gone the craziest but
they've all gone the craziest in the
direction of the left so the fact that
you had some of these elite universities
questioning right the left-wing
political narrative right that should
have raised some bells and I think the
key here I don't think you need to be a
crazy conspiracy theorist to realize
that there is a political dimension to
public health of the question
and you just saw I mean it they gave
they gave it away last week which is you
saw I think it was what 1200 or more
public health officials who signed into
a letter and they said look riots are
great the riots are great so if as long
as you are rioting now for the left then
that's good that's actually that
actually helps suppress coronavirus
right and in the same letter they said
if you protest peacefully against the
lockdowns that's gonna spread the
coronavirus I mean it was it was absurd
on its face but what they admitted was
this is not about medical science this
is about politics if you look at the
reaction the response that we were told
we had to take in response to this yeah
the entire thing if we did a rundown of
it it would be the proto version of the
green new deal right yes government
decides what businesses are essential or
non-essential so apparently if you're a
family-owned business anywhere in
America you are not capable of
sanitizing your workplace only Lowe's
Home Depot Costco massive big-box stores
they are capable of doing it but you
have a family business you're not right
so government decides what businesses
are essential or non-essential where you
get to travel and by what method and
with how many people and with whom I
mean there was even a part it was you
know that scene in Avengers endgame when
Captain America shows up in the mid five
years after the snap and he shows up and
he says to Black Widow I know hey no
human beings there's you know that's
less pollution in the Hudson
whales in there I cannot believe it it
actually happened in real life they
started writing articles about how hey
not people doing anything it's like this
is great for the environment and we see
we're seeing what's going on in the
oceans better it was it was very clear
that at some 4-5 minutes maybe and I'm
giving people that benefit out when I
say that for five minutes this was about
oh crap you know what this virus mutated
in ways we've not seen a SARS
coronavirus dude uncharted territory
here ok but then of course yeah the
reason I only gave him five minutes is
the nations that were closest to China
Japan South Korea they did not do what
we did they deal with these sorts of
outbreaks all the time they didn't do a
mass lockdown Yeah right why didn't we
listen to them but five minutes later it
was very clear that this became about
how can I use this virus to advance my
agenda and it's the same story you see
now at the race riots for five minutes
this was about what happened to George
Ford right and the rest of the time this
has been about how can I use this to
advance a racialist agenda
[Music]
you
[Music]